all right before we get to the comment
section this is um
a viral video that is uh
maybe the most important maybe the most
important subject we can cover today is
a viral video about someone's experience
at Disney World and they posted this to
tick tock talking about how much they
they spend at Disney World and uh yeah
I've never been to Disney World I never
plan on going to Disney World I've
always been aware that it's expensive
but this surprised me even let's watch
this
so here's how much we spent at Disney
day two or five a mediocre breakfast at
Hollywood and Vine cost us 223 dollars
then we headed over to Toy Story Land
and even when lightning Lane we still
only got to ride one ride
ice cream was 25 and popcorn was 16.
then over at Galaxy's Edge three
lightsabers cost us a whopping eight
hundred dollars they also no longer hold
them for you until the end of the day
plus different airlines have different
restrictions when flying home so we
opted to ship them to us for an
additional cost
every ride had a 120 minute wait signs
so we only got to ride one ride in this
section of the park as well we tried the
infamous blue and green milk and had
lunch at back line and funnel cakes at
Epic East PhotoPass was an extra hundred
and seventy dollars for cell phone
quality pictures and finally we had
dinner at Planet Hollywood factoring in
our 90 Hotel rate of 997 dollars brings
our total to
3758 dollars
oh my I'm sorry I I don't even know
where to start was that 800 on
lightsabers did I hear that right I'm
actually not sure if I heard that right
was it 800 on lightsabers it was 800 how
many lightsabers what was it was it was
it 50 lightsabers
three three lightsabers eight hundred
dollars on three were they real like
they better be real lightsabers like an
actual laser that can cut things in half
uh and deflect you know other lasers
that are being shot at you I can't
really go on much much more detail about
how lightsabers work but uh if they're
real lightsabers then I could see maybe
spending that kind of money on it but
I'm expecting I suspect that they're not
and that the laser is actually made of
plastic and so you're spending 800 on
that I mean I I
like even if you're even if you're a
millionaire I think spending that kind
of money on a plastic toy is it
exorbitant and gratuitous expense I
can't
understand this like we you know we all
we all some of us work for a living and
you get you don't get a lot of time off
uh and it's Precious Precious time when
you have off especially if you have a
family and you want to spend time with
your family and so yeah let's say you
have a week off and you decide that you
want to spend
that week down in the Heat and in the in
the humidity
standing in lines among crowds of
tourists these are all things that I
like spend my life trying to avoid you
have a week off and you're gonna you're
gonna pay money for the privilege of
standing in lines and being around huge
crowds in the Heat and the humidity and
and spending was it 300 300 on
at best like Applebee's tier food like
this is Applebee's food at at the best
and you're spending 300 bucks on it at
dinner
Biden's plans to help struggling
business owners in the wake of coveted
lockdowns were to prioritize black
latino Native American and women-owned
businesses well it goes without saying
that if the roles were reversed if Biden
had said that his plans were to
prioritize white male loan businesses
there would have been outrage to say the
least so if you own a business you can't
rely on the government to bail you out
that's the moral of the story you need
to take matters into your own hands and
Innovation refunds can help you do just
that if your business has five or more
employees and it managed to survive
covid well you could be eligible to
receive a payroll tax rebate of up to 26
thousand dollars per employee through
the employee retention credit all you
gotta do is go to getrefunds.com
Innovation refunds has already helped
clients claim over three billion dollars
in payroll tax refunds through the ERC
and they may be able to help your
business too this is not a loan there's
no payback it's a refund of your taxes
there's no upfront charge either they
don't get paid until your business gets
paid and gets its refund so don't let
this opportunity pass you by see if your
business qualifies for ERC assistance in
just eight minutes go to getrefunds.com
click on qualify me and answer a few
questions this payroll tax refund is
only available for a limited amount of
time
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
getrefunds.com
um
everything about that seems
horrific to me and but people choose to
endorse and not only this was what makes
okay
if you're a parent you have kids
and you decide that you want to go
through all of this for the sake of your
kids I think it's misguided I think it's
a mistake you don't you and I think you
don't need to do this you can give your
child a wonderful time you can make
memories with your child and spend a
third of the money and have way more fun
but at least it's the thought that
counts and so if you decide I want to go
down to Disney World for the sake of my
kids and spend fifty thousand dollars on
cheap plastic toys and crappy food and
waiting in line for three hours so that
I can ride two rides for the whole week
that were there if you decide you want
to do that for your child you know it I
mean it's a sacrifice this is a
sacrifice and I and I uh misguided but I
can respect that
but there are adults who do who do this
without kids for their
for themselves
I mean imagine that for a second you're
an adult you can you you have some time
off of work you don't have any kids you
obviously have the fact that you're
going to Disney World News you have a
lot of expendable income and you could
go anywhere in the world right you could
it's like if you have no kids in your
adult you have expandable income the
whole the world's your oyster you can go
anywhere on vacation
and you decide to go to Disney World
you know what you could do my wife and I
we can't do this right now you get on a
plane and you could fly in the
summertime to Alaska
where it's beautiful and it gets 70
degrees you know at the height of the
summer and it's sunny almost all day in
the summer in Alaska and there's just
wildlife and it's the most beautiful one
of the most beautiful places on Earth
that you can go to and you can and you
can bask in that natural beauty and have
quiet and fresh air and everything and
you say no I don't want that I want to
go
and and sweat myself in huge crowds of
people
I don't understand
it is a it's a it's the last thing I'll
say
and I think at least we can agree on
this part maybe up to now you don't
agree but at least we can say that
adults who enjoy Disney World are
mentally ill there's a there's obviously
some sort of mental illness going on
here
um I don't know if it's in the DSM or
not but I think more research needs to
be done on that now do it for us today
we'll talk to you tomorrow have a great
day Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign